У шведських лісах призовники знову проходять військові навчання
Молоді військовослужбовці
готуються захищати країну у разі потреби
З цього року шведи проходитимуть 11-місячну військову службу після школи
Як хлопці, так і дівчата
Для мене це само собою зрозуміло
Це корисно, і, думаю, я б робила це і добровільно
Сім’я та друзі думають, що я маю залишитися
Більшість вважає, що це буде моєю професією
Сам я ще не впевнений, але мені дуже подобається
За останні 15 років більшість європейських країн
зробили свої армії професійними
Лише у десяти європейських країнах все ще є військова повинність
Після анексії Криму та війни в Україні
в Європі спалахнула дискусія про повернення до обов'язкової військової служби
Литва та Швеція вже це зробили
Коли Росія анексує Крим, йде конфлікт в Україні
та є військова присутність і діяльність у Балтійському морі
майже на наших кордонах
нам потрібно посилити нашу обороноздатність
Тому необхідна загальна військова повинність
У військово нейтральній Швеції повернення до військової повинності
не є великою темою в суспільстві
Я не вірю в професійну армію,
всі мають брати участь
Раніше я теж проходив військову службу
і мені це подобалося
Треба захищати свою країну
Я думаю, це добре, якщо дівчата і хлопці чомусь навчатимуться перед тим
як отримувати вищу освіту
Крім поводження зі зброєю
молоді шведи також навчаються речам
які вони мали б засвоїти ще вдома
Ми навчаємо їх застеляти ліжка
і піклуватися один про одного
Це дуже відрізняється від сучасного суспільства
Тут ми не особистість, а група
Цього року у Швеції призвали лише близько чотирьох відсотків випускників шкіл
та ще 4000 молодих людей
Для більшості ж військова повинність і досі
залишається лише на папері